[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Nick is
there Nick how can we help hey Ken hey
Jade how are you guys doing today we're
having a blast what's
up so uh my wife and I are in a bit of a
pickle uh some background real quick is
uh we just got married a few months ago
uh we had a really expensive last year
with weddings and our wedding and all
that uh we got through it all we
combined our finances and uh we started
tackling a big mountain of student loans
and uh various smaller loans together
here the last few
months um so we're in the middle of baby
step 2 and uh we recently got invited
and actually uh my wife was asked to be
in the wedding we got invited to a
wedding out of the country o
where uh it's in Italy ah I love that
always oh my goodness so and she's
supposed to be part of the bridal party
too which is even more expensive cuz you
got the dresses and the activities and
the laa um how much debt do you guys
have uh we are we have about 97,000 left
okay 97,000 left and um who who is this
person to you whose wedding is this uh
it's one of her best friends um not
family or anything but like recent best
friends or best friends from high school
or from college like is this person in
her daily life dayto day
uh I would say I mean they've been best
friends for the last four or five years
I wouldn't say since they grew up
together like they didn't grow up
together is she the maid of
honor no okay so she's not the maid of
honor which means she ain't the best
friend unless the girl has a sister it
does matter in this it does matter okay
right I um I'm going to shoot you
straight here because I don't think that
you guys can afford a trip to
Italy and I don't think that you can
afford all of the things that goes along
with being a bridesmaid because in 2023
these Brides made prices have gone
through the roof yeah what are we
talking about do we have a price tag I'm
curious Nick it's it's the parties it's
everything so what what do you think
it's going to cost so um the whole thing
is about four days I believe that's the
minim the minimum like stay and that's
not even including travel I priced out
to about 6,000 that's if we just did the
4 days and that's for the two of
you I mean yeah flights I can't find
anything
under uh like four grand for two flights
right and then there's tuxedo dresses is
that is that everything
included yeah the the next question I
have is do you have
$6,000 um we don't um we did save a
little bit of our um we got some money
from the wedding and we put most of it
towards our debt
um and we did save about 3,000 of it in
case we decided to go to Italy so what's
the pickle because that implies to me
that you maybe you guys aren't on the
same page is that
true yeah I mean she's all in on going
friend kind of I'm on the we can't
afford it side but I don't want to come
between let me ask you this cuz if it
were me if I were you um in in the in
the script was flipped and it was my
husband who wanted to go for his friends
I would say what would you think about
us throwing a really nice bridal shower
or in this case Grooms party for your
friend here stayside and we can do that
and that way we're finding a way to
participate doing something nice but we
can also keep it within a much smaller
scope all right come on and not I that's
Jay the financial expert and the very
disciplined person who changed her life
you're legit but come on I want I want J
the woman on this okay so like if he
says that to his wife I think she goes
sorry pal that's not a viable option I
have a way to meet in the I got one I
got one okay hit him Ken he doesn't go
he says babe this is your dear friend I
know that that would pain you not to go
it's a big deal but babe we are in fin
,000 he can go make
$3,000 yeah when is the when is the trip
in June okay between now no I'm okay if
don't like this I don't know how I feel
I'm still marinating good because I am
trying to help this man in his marriage
and and and I am asking you as a woman
to get real If This Were you and Sam and
this was your really good friend and you
were in come on now all right Ken he has
no option but to work his butt off he
can sell stuff make some money come up
with and I don't think it's three grand
she goes I think can the and and Nick
we're we're arguing this for you he's
got to say something hold on go ahead
if it's any consolation we're putting
about thousand a month towards our debt
exactly this is a cash flow situation
exactly and and for me I'm like if you
can just go out and earn $33,000 for a
wedding I'm like I all I see is your
debt going from 97 down to 94 that's
what I see I'm like look with almost
$100,000 of debt how long have you guys
been working the the baby step 2 how
long have you been in it it's been like
two and a half months you you're just
getting started I all I see is his wife
resenting him for years to come when
she's looking at Instagram and seeing
the wedding picture she's not she's not
because what get her on the phone I'm
telling you I'm right on this one she
she's going to be she she's going to be
mad for a minute but here's the thing
can I don't even talk about my wedding
on a weekly basis a monthly basis or a
yearly basis it's not even her day she's
going to get over it you're the
exception oh she's going to get over it
all K colan you looked at your wedding
album man I'm a dude but this is a woman
w weddings to women is a whole different
I'm a woman too I just gave you the
perspective I just don't think you're
keeping it real well okay the man is
calling us with a money and relationship
question and I am trying to help him
with both look Nick what are you leaning
towards after you heard Ken and I chop
it chop it up what do you think I it's
just I'm between pausing the debt and
saving up some money and just you know
going the minimum that we need to be
there um we also postponed our honeymoon
we didn't do a honeymoon because and we
honestly we underestimated how expensive
Italy was going to be that was supposed
to be and see that's the thing you
didn't do your own honeymoon to do this
okay do he's on the phone talking I want
you to understand you're grown so you're
going to walk away and do what you want
and whatever makes you sleep at night
however what I do want to tell you is
you're just getting started and the
choices that you make now are setting
the tone for your whole baby step two
Journey so the moment that you start
saying this is the exception or that's
the exception you're you're you're
creating age that you're creating a rule
with this decision I agree with you I'm
trying to help him out like I I cuz I
got the Feeling we running out of time
with him but I have the feeling his wife
is really like I'm going she wants to go
everybody wants to go to Italy and
everybody wants to be in their friend's
wedding I'm not saying that that's not
the case don't no dude in the world any
dude's like yeah sorry pal I can't
afford this but women is a different
deal so I want to see you sit down and
have a candlelight dinner conversation
with Mama and see where she's really at
and then if you really have to split the
difference my option is a viable option
and not stop paying the debt I don't
want him to slow down say he going to
cash flow it on top of paying the debt
off I know I wish I was as hardcore as
you I'm not this is the ramsy show
create your free every doll budget today
the simplest way to budget for your life